kevin federline is getting candid about
co-parenting with britney spears it's
tough it's real tough Kevin and Britney
share custody of their two sons
ten-year-old Jaden and 11 year old
Preston and the pair makes co-parenting
a priority
he told Robbo's personal space quote you
fall into your routine and it's really
easy now it wasn't always easy me and
Britt are good it's it's you know
everybody knows I've had a tough road
but I'm happy where we're at I'm really
blessed Brittany is currently on tour
and brought their boys along which means
the 39 year old DJ didn't see Jaden and
Preston for Father's Day but admits he's
used to not having all his kids quote
when you are co-parenting you have to be
willing to give up some of the things
you would really like to do for the sake
of our kids it's always been that way
but when he does spend quality time with
his sons kevin says he's helping one tap
into his musical talents he says quote
Preston kind of knows how to DJ he wants
to learn more
adding he's really big into the EDM trap
music scene